[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique elle a une ce soir tension
partiellement retombée au Tchad au
lendemain d'une journée d'une violence
inédite lors des manifestations
anti-pouvoirs 50 morts à travers le pays
et la suspension des activités des
principales structures de l'opposition
nous irons sur place dans ce journal
Ibrahim Traoré auteur du coup d'État du
30 septembre investi président de
transition du Burkina Faso à 34 ans il
devient le plus jeune dirigeant au monde
c'est le deuxième pucciste investi par
le Conseil constitutionnel et qui jure
devant la Constitution en 8 mois
seulement
et ce soir nous recevons un grand maître
de la peinture africaine ce n'est pas un
titre
usurpé après de 70 ans Abdoulaye Konaté
propose une oeuvre virevoltante et
élaborée autour du tissu et de la
couleur l'artiste malien est engagé et
présente une oeuvre critique des enjeux
géopolitiques avec une esthétique bien à
lui il est artiste invité pour
l'installation monumentale 2022 de la
foire d'art contemporain aka qui s'est
ouvert à Paris ce vendredi
on ouvre ce journal par la situation au
Tihad au lendemain de ce qui est déjà à
la journée la plus meurtrière du pays
après des manifestations antipouvoir 50
morts et plus de 300 blessés pour avoir
voulu contester l'extension de la
transition et le maintien au pouvoir de
Mahamad Idriss Déby hypno un couvre-feu
de 18h à 6h du matin a été décrété à
niameyna mounoudou et d'autres villes et
jusqu'à rétablissement total de l'ordre
les précisions de notre correspondant
Mamadou
une journée calme jamais dans la
capitale se réveille difficilement des
douloureuses événements d'hier qui ont
fait une cinquantaine de morts et plus
de 300 blessés selon le gouvernement
l'opposition quant à elle elle parle de
plus de 80 morts le chef de gouvernement
ça les kebabo qui a animé hier une
conférence de presse en fin d'après-midi
à accusé les organisateurs de ces
manifestations de fomenter un coup
d'état par une insurrection armée de
même il a annoncé deux mesures
conservatoires prises par son
gouvernement il s'agit de l'instauration
d'un couvre-feu de 18h à 6h du matin à
Djamena est dans trois villes de
province ainsi que la suspension des
activités des partis politiques et
associations impliquées dans ces
manifestations il a aussi laissé
entendre que le gouvernement se réserve
le doigt le droit de les poursuivre en
justice sur ce dernier point nous avons
joué l'un des chefs des parties
concernées docteur kersani qui dirige le
parti les patriotes qui lui jugent ces
mesures arbit et sans fondement
juridique lui aussi se réserve le doit
rester en justice le président des
transition à Mama Idriss Déby Itno dont
les manifestations contestent sa
recondition à la tête de la transition à
visiter cet après-midi les blessés dans
dans les différents hôpitaux d'examena
il a aussi fait une visite dans le siège
du parti du chef du gouvernement actuel
et l'ancien tous deux qui ont été
saccagés par les manifestants
le capitaine Ibrahim Traoré a été
investi président du Burkina Faso trois
semaines après son coup d'État c'est le
deuxième pucciste en huit mois a juré
sur l'honneur son honneur de préserver
respecter et de défendre la Constitution
devant le Conseil constitutionnel les
détails de notre correspondant
d'énormes défis attendent désormais le
capitaine Ibrahim Traoré au terme de
cette transition notamment les pneuses
qui sont sécuritaires et c'est sans
doute que les Burkinabè le jugeront sur
cette problématique mais cela passera
par la cohésion au sein des Forces de
défense et de sécurité qui semblent être
fissurées depuis le coup d'État de 30
septembre dernier dans son discours de
circonstance dans cette salle de la Cour
constitutionnelle devant les forces
vives de la nation et les responsables
des forces armées il a exhorté
l'ensemble de l'armée l'ensemble de la
troupe à plus d'unité car dit-il nous
devons taire nos différents face à ces
groupes armées qui sont de plus en plus
unis si les volontaires pour la défense
de la patrie les VDP sont unis nous les
hommes en tenue nous n'avons pas le
droit fin des citations
le capitaine Traoré c'est également
engagé à respecter tous les engagements
pris par son pays envers les partenaires
internationaux à 34 ans le capitaine
Traoré a 21 mois à compter de ce mois
d'octobre pour conquérir les 40% du
territoire qui va certainement permettre
le retour des 2 millions de déplacer qui
connaissent actuellement le pays
on passe à la République démocratique du
Congo ou le cardinal de Kinshasa a remis
son rapport au Premier ministre un
rapport attendu après la mission sa
mission dans l'ouest du pays une région
secouée par des violences qui ont
entraîné la mort de 150 personnes y
pousser des milliers d'autres à fuir les
précisions d'Aurélie bazarra qui
bancgoula
le cardinal Fridolin Bongo a tenu à
mettre les choses au clair pour lui il
s'agit d'un conflit entre les tequets
propriétaires de terre dans le
territoire du kwammouth et toutes les
autres communautés qui ont acheté ou qui
louent leur terre dans cette partie de
l'ouest du pays et ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudres c'est la brusque
augmentation de la redevance coutumière
expédition punitive village entier
brûlés au moins 150 personnes ont été
tuées et 35000 sont déplacés selon les
Nations Unies le cardinal fridola en
Bongo mettant garde les autorités de
Kinshasa car c'est violent s'étendent
déjà dans le territoire du coamouth et
pourrait atteindre Kinshasa la capitale
congolaise si rien n'est fait pour
apaiser les tensions
si un événement comme ça se passe
et qu'on sous-estime
en sachant que la population de Masséna
est essentiellement composée des peuples
provenant du Grand Bandung
et essentiellement des bâtiés et des
bayaka vous risquez
d'avoir les répercussions de ce qui se
passe à quoi vous demain ici dans la
ville de Kinshasa particulièrement à
Masséna le cardinal c'est aussi
interrogé sur de possibles manipulations
il affirme que ces violences rappellent
et celles de yumbi une localité située
au nord de kouammouth des violences qui
avaient éclaté en 2018 elles aussi à la
veille des élections une thèse déjà
évoquée par le président Félix
Tshisekedi qui avait dénoncé une main
noire qui chercherait selon lui à sa
beauté le bon déroulement des élections
prévues fin 2023
trois morts une dizaine de blessés
plusieurs arrestations en Guinée c'est
le bilan des affrontements jeudi entre
des jeunes manifestants et les forces de
l'ordre à Conakry efndc une coalition
des partis politiques syndicats et
successives avaient appelé ces
manifestants dans la rue pour dénoncer
la gestion de la transition par les
militaires au pouvoir ce vendredi un
calme précaire règne dans la capitale
guinéenne le mouvement appelle de
nouvelles manifestations mercredi
prochain imagine de Malik Diakité
notre invité de ce soir est née à direr
au Mali en 1953 et sa passion du dessin
le prend dès les années 60 son travail
pictural et monumental et son engagement
total il utilise le tissu comme une
palette à partir de laquelle il compose
une œuvre percutante et haute en couleur
Abdoulaye Konaté merci d'être avec nous
sur le plateau du journal de l'Afrique
de France 24 merci beaucoup alors on ne
peut pas évidemment vous recevoir
sachant votre engagement sans parler de
la situation au Mali dans votre pays on
voulait savoir tout d'abord en
préliminaire avant de parler de votre
travail comment est-ce que vous
ressentez l'actualité dans votre pays
c'est vrai que la situation
pas seulement au Mali dans toute la
bande du Sahel elle est très compliquée
et c'est dommage d'avoir tant de mots
dans une période comme ça
en Afrique après tant d'années
d'indépendance tant d'années de
formation et voir le nombre de morts sur
nos territoires aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment dommage
n'échappe pas
à cette situation malheureusement dans
cette zone d'Afrique et nous prions pour
que ça s'arrête quoi
alors vous vous proposez parlons de
votre travail à présent on a vu cette
oeuvre monumentale présentée à haka ce
vendredi qui sera qui a déjà qui s'est
ouverte cette foire d'art contemporain à
Paris voilà et je voulais savoir avant
qu'on parle de cette œuvre
vous avez été vous avez été reçu à clamé
à la Biennale de Dakar aujourd'hui vous
êtes l'artiste invité de haka comment
est-ce que vous vivez voilà cette
j'allais dire ce nouveau regard parce
que voilà votre carrière est déjà faite
et lancée depuis longtemps comment vous
vivez cette nouvelle attention si je
puis dire cette c'est marques
d'attention oui je pense beaucoup plus
un effort collectif de tous les artistes
qui travaillent
sur ce thème d'Afrique et qui
aujourd'hui on sent que
ils sont sur le marché international ils
sont sur la scène internationale ils
sont dans des grands musées ils sont
dans les grosses collections
je pense et tout c'était fort là qui
nous accompagne aujourd'hui
c'est pas qu'on a tous seuls c'est tous
ces artistes qui ont travaillé à
un groupe pendant des années qui
commencent à faire émerger
d'avoir les plus anciens mais aussi
aujourd'hui les plus jeunes alors on
connaît votre modestie qui est
légendaire mais n'empêche que vous êtes
affublé du titre de Grand Maître et
beaucoup de jeunes se réclament de vous
et comme vous êtes très attaché à la
transmission j'imagine que ça au moins
ça vous fait plaisir oui j'aime beaucoup
l'enseignement j'aime beaucoup
transmettre et parce que j'ai bénéficié
de ça comme beaucoup d'artistes
je pense c'est essentiel aujourd'hui
pour nous pour
permettre aux jeunes de comprendre
comment fonctionne la comment il faut
faire pour travailler dans ce secteur là
mais surtout pour leur donner confiance
dire que avec l'art aujourd'hui c'est
possible de tenir c'est possible reste
dans nos pays et de vivre de ça
alors parlons un petit peu de cette
œuvre donc qui qui est à cas qui a du
bleu et il me semble qu'il y a un donc
tout un hommage aussi fait il y a un
lien avec l'actualité et ce qui se passe
dans dans la région du Sahel
expliquez-nous justement en quelques
mots ce que cette oeuvre représente et
symbolique toute la série présentée à
travail sur ce lien culturel qui existe
entre les pays du Maghreb et toute la
bande du Sahel donc je m'inspire surtout
de fonds traditionnel
de de grandes
tapisseries des grandes broderies des
pays du Maghreb
on remarque que nous trouvons des
symboles
presque identiques dans le texte style
au niveau du Maroc au niveau de
l'Algérie de la Tunisie de la Mauritanie
et qu'on retrouve au Mali au Niger au
Burkina un peu au signal dans toute
cette bande là on trouve des éléments de
culture qui sont très très anciens et
j'essaie d'exploiter ça et de le faire
revenir pour montrer le lien entre les
différentes parties de cet Afrique et
est-ce qu'il y a un lien avec les
Touaregs et j'ai vu que
je prends des symboles qu'on trouve chez
les Touareg chez les Berbères et
les couleurs les couleurs vertes
qu'utilisent les toilettes le bleu
qu'ils utilisent comme dans la tenue et
ce que j'ai pu remarquer chez eux dans
l'utilisation des couleurs on trouve le
verre les différentes gammes de verre
dans leur artisanat mais dans leur tenue
bleu on ne trouve pas de vert dans leur
tenue par contre dans tout l'artisanat
donc j'essaie de décortiquer le goût
mais aussi comment ces couleurs sont
utilisées en Afrique alors dites-nous
d'où vous vient parce que votre
particularité aussi c'est de travailler
à partir du tissu et vous utilisez je le
disais en introduction le tissu comme
une palette finalement un peu pour moi
c'est de la peinture quoi voilà c'est de
la peinture je l'utilise comme peintre
en peinture bon je les appelle textiles
à certains qui disent ta piscine
d'autres disent sculptures parce que
c'est en trois dimensions mais je les
utilise comme peinture et
j'ai commencé à travailler sur
le textile à partir des années 90 quand
j'ai commencé à faire les grandes
installations et j'ai vu que le textile
pouvait me permettre de m'exprimer
en dehors de ce qu'on a appris à l'école
et on a fait ses formations académiques
avec l'anatomie avec les paysans et tout
mais je me suis approprié aujourd'hui le
textile pour m'exprimer absolument pour
le plus grand bonheur de justement tout
ce qui vous suivent et qui aiment votre
travail
on lisait tout à l'heure vous êtes
sensible la transmission notamment vers
les jeunes et notamment sur ce fond
d'art africains justement financé en
partie au départ par les œuvres des
artistes africains
à partir d'une réunion officielle
avec des amis avec mahmoudafé qui qui
dirige le festival
à Ségou là
et on a créé le front africain pour la
culture parce que il faut il faut le
dire fortement parce que on se rend
compte que les États africains ne
financent pas la culture les budget de
la culture sont presque
la dernière partie de des budget des
différents ministères et on se dit que
les artistes eux aussi peuvent
contribuer contribuer c'est comme ça que
est né le front africain et on demande à
des grands artistes africains de faire
des donations
c'est un qui donne deux trois heures
qu'on va et
il y a un appel à candidature il y a un
conseil d'administration on fait un
appel à candidature les les artistes qui
sont missionnent et il y a un jeu
international qui sélectionne les
dossiers et voilà merci beaucoup
Abdoulaye Konaté d'être venu je pense
que le message est passé merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont regardé c'est la fin
du journal de dire et au Mali à Bamako
en passant par Paris restez avec nous
car il a été continué sur France 24
[Musique]